this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the villains of Dragon Ball have become
some of the most memorable and
recognizable in the history of anime and
one of the essential keys to success for
any good villain is their real
Dragon Ball has some of the best villain
introductions and reveals in the history
of anime however not all of them are
spectacular but before I break down how
these scenes work
I'd like you to cast your vote here on
what your favorite villain introduction
was before watching this video at the
end of this video I'll give you a second
chance to cast your vote and let's see
if your opinion changes it might not be
as persuasive as Frieza but I do have a
decent understanding of how these scenes
were written why many of them work and
why others might not work as well I'm
totally not mark and this is Dragon Ball
mastering the evil introduction I was
told flat-out I'd never obtain a single
Dragon Ball and since I've never been
one to take bad news well I'm afraid I
killed him
[Music]
within the first scene of a story it's
possible for the reader or viewer to
judge the skill of the writer simply by
noting how he handles exposition
exposition is basically the information
the audience needs in order to
understand the story usually it's the
dialogue or the action that moves the
plot forward keeping the audience in the
same page as the characters on screen
for instance in the case of Raddatz
Goku's origins and the reveal of the
Saiyan race is the information or
exposition the audience needs to
understand the story moving forward and
so Akira Toriyama the writer was tasked
to deliver that information in his
natural way as possible in other words
the best kind of exposition is the
exposition you don't realize you're
receiving or at least that's what famous
screenwriter Robert McKee writes in his
book story he says never force words
into a character's mouth to tell the
audience about world history or person
rather show us honest natural scenes in
which human beings talk and behave in
honest natural ways yet at the same time
indirectly pass along the necessary
facts and funnily enough a scene that
has terrific examples of good and bad
exposition can be found here run its
remarks you're all grown up but I could
tell it was you in a glance Kakarot my
how you look like our father
Goku mutters Kakarot to himself confused
Raddatz demands an explanation and a
mission report citing his expectations
and confusion scene Goku still confused
Crillon decides to try and talk right
it's down only to be met by this is a
good example of a relatively natural way
of delivering dialogue it communicates
raditz and Goku's connection visually
with his tale and most importantly it
doesn't shove information down our
throats in an overly clunky and somewhat
condescending manner so what comes next
dialog that shove down our throats at an
overly clunky and somewhat condescending
manner it tells us the entire backstory
of Raddatz
the sayings and Goku's origin and it's
not just Dragon Ball that has this
problem anime is filled with this sort
of exposition that forum is too much of
a drain on your energy everything you
had and so now that we know what makes
for good dramatized exposition let's
take a look at this character my name is
perfect sell and I'd like to say hello
this is without a doubt one of the best
villain introductions in the entire
series and if I want to be thorough
which I do every subsequent introduction
for his individual transformations has
something to enjoy however if you want
to learn how to introduce your villain
with as little dialog as possible
check this out information gets out that
something suspicious is happening in
ginger town keep in mind that at this
point in the story the androids
are the center of attention piccolo
arrives on the scene dead silent the
camera pans across a vacant sprawling
city littered with random articles of
clothing the use of camera angles and
sound effects is incredibly creative and
makes for a sinister atmosphere viewing
piccolo from across the street as if we
the audience are peering from an
alleyway someone is watching piccolo
slowly pieces of information are fed to
the audience we hear ominous sounds like
footsteps the dragging of something
across the floor and a sinister
silhouette cutting through the light
from the shadows
suddenly piccolo turns his head he hears
something suddenly the episode becomes
very quiet the splash of water droplets
echo in the ghost town the scene
progresses and slowly measured amounts
of information are revealed to us until
we finally see him fade to black
this was brilliant and it tells us a lot
about cell before he even says a word we
know that he doesn't want to be seen can
conceal his location doesn't necessarily
want anything to do with piccolo or the
other warriors but is confident enough
in his ability to confront piccolo
without the element of surprise so he
must be strong we got all of that from
cinematography it's exceptional so
what's next
[Music]
I want to preface this by saying I don't
dislike King Piccolo as a villain I
think he's fun
but his introduction might as well have
been him reading from the script but
it's not all bad so let's begin with the
good once the World Martial Arts
Tournament concludes Crillon is found
dead and alone murdered by a strange
never-before-seen monster having made
off with tournament competitor list and
a Dragon Ball this works is a great way
to open an arc it incites intrigue and
ask the audience and ignites rage within
Goku so that's good smash cut to inside
king piccolo ship the first thing he
says is if you gather all seven any wish
will be granted a he proceeds then to
tell us exactly what he wants to wish
for and why this serves literally no
purpose within the context of this
conversation its only purpose is to
communicate the motivations of the
villain in a short time span as possible
to us the readers or viewers
specifically for all intents and
purposes he may as well have been
winking at the camera as he said it
certainly not invisible exposition I
mean if you think about it if the
monster that murdered Krillin Tambourine
made off with the tournament roster and
a Dragon Ball then that means his orders
would have been given to him prior to
this entire conversation between King
Piccolo and pilaf yet right here piccolo
is acting as though this is the first
time he's heard of it this is lazy
writing dealing with knotty problems of
expositions so intimidates some writers
that they try to get it all out of the
way as soon as possible Robert McKee
this is very much the issue with much of
Toriyama's early stories it's the exact
problem with the right at scene Akira
Toriyama had a tendency to cram as much
exposition
into the first act or even the first
chapter as he could in order to focus on
other aspects of the story like the
conflicts and the climax aspects of
storytelling he had a natural aptitude
for this exposition faux pas affected
most characters in early Dragonball
Raddatz Vegeta nappa however it started
to fade away leading into the NAM exciti
resulting in this scene no Anita on the
tip here while you Deford my friend but
you will kindly answer our questions in
the same language with which they were
addressed to you not this gibberish now
I've touched on this scene before in
this video but man is this scene
fantastic and it's filled with some
sensational characterization for freeze
if you didn't know him before this scene
afterwards you will know next to
everything about him and what he stands
for in the past I've brought attention
to the striking similarities between
this scene and the opening of inglorious
basterds
and I stand behind this as one of
freezes absolute best scenes everything
from his choice of words to the
inflection he uses and the air of murder
that fills the air when he starts to get
annoyed Frieza in this scene is very
much playing up for the theatrics of it
all indeed he was most adamant about
that point try as we might though we
could not get him to say no at least not
before we decided to kill one of them
during this scene we learned that Frieza
is filled with self-importance he's
intelligent and he only accepts
cooperation utilizing fear and his power
to get what he wants the situation also
serves as a natural means to communicate
to us that he wants the Dragon Balls it
lets us know that Gohan and krillen are
in the know and thanks to the Scouters
Vegeta is - this is a spectacular scene
that for me really ticks all the boxes
but this next one might just be better
it's about time saying Dragon Ball super
had its ups and downs and definitely
introducing its antagonist was one of
the areas in which it lacked his ass
Jaron was meditating in silence as
people told us why he was cool it was
sitting there to be clear I don't
actively dislike hit I'm more
indifferent about him but one
character's debut that absolutely
without question blew the rest of the
competition out of the water was Goku
black
[Music]
while other characters were given a
short scene to establish themselves Goku
black got an entire episode and let me
tell you they made full use of that time
establishing this character from the
very first scene he's built up as this
force of nature pursuing trunks through
a hellscape of his design immediately
this communicates that this character is
unlike anything we have seen before and
that trunks is in dire straits through
the runtime of this episode we are shown
the consequences his presence has
wrought on this world with no seen
better encapsulating that than this one
the stage is finally set for the reveal
standing atop his altar above all of
humanity surrounded by flames and
destruction trunks sits crying with a
woman he loves lifeless in his arms Goku
black is unmasked utterly spectacular I
wouldn't change a single thing now that
we're nearing the end I would like to
invite you to cast your vote a second
time which of these four characters do
you think had the best introduction
click here and let your vote be counted
over the last number of decades Dragon
Ball has garnered a reputation as being
an anime without any substance
however labeling it as such is an
overgeneralization in my view and does a
disservice to its spectacular and
carefully crafted characterization the
villains that inhabit the pages of
Dragon Ball are colorful over-the-top
and in some cases campy but there is no
denying that you know all of their
personalities front to back creating
gripping scenarios scripts and
characters doesn't happen by accident it
takes careful planning and a measured
approach so in the scenes where it works
I think it's important to appreciate
Akira Toriyama's evil introductions
thanks for watching
I let to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video Squarespace is
a service that allows you to create and
customize your own website with ease if
you need a blog somewhere to host your
artwork or want a place for your
business online build that website with
Squarespace they offer common management
systems through their mobile apps and
have fantastic design templates to
choose from when you design they really
are a one-stop shop when it comes to
starting your own website and the best
part you can start your free trial today
at squarespace.com and if you use offer
code totally not Marc you can get 10%
off your first purchase thank you again
and I'll see you next week
[Music]
you